the hogwarts legacy trailer has harry
potter fans everywhere buzzing with
excitement at all the possibilities for
an open world action rpg
set in the wizarding world i know you
guys are excited
i'm certainly excited and today i want
to share with you 10 features we
absolutely need to see in hogwarts
legacy people of the internet
retro rack and tour here if we're
meeting for the first time i'm just a
dad who loves games and the stories they
tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube and also stream over on twitch
in today's video i'll be going over 10
features i would love to see
make it into hogwarts legacy as we go
through each feature idea i'll also give
you my guess on how likely i think we
are to see it actually in the final game
obviously we still have some time before
the game hits and even though we've seen
one official trailer there are still a
lot of unknowns about the game
we know it will have its own story but
how close will it stick to the rules of
the wizarding world we already know and
love
i think these 10 features would excite
long time fans of the series and would
go
a long way to show how much avalanche
wants to please fans of the books
and movies after you've made it through
the full list let me know down in the
comments below which feature you'd want
to see the most
and with that let's get into the list
number one
animagi we meet our first animagi within
the first few
scenes of harry potter and the
sorcerer's stone as minerva mcgonagall
waits patiently for the arrival of baby
harry at number 4 privet drive
as the series progresses animagi become
even more prominent especially in
prisoner of azkaban when we learn about
james potter and his marauder companions
book readers may recall this more easily
than movie only fans as there were quite
a few details here that the movies
failed to show
sirius black remus lupin james potter
and peter pettigrew were the best of
friends throughout their time at
hogwarts
lupine was actually bitten and changed
into a werewolf as a child
when his friends learned of the
affliction they all decided to become
anime jai in order to keep him company
sirius became a dog peter became a rat
and james became a stag
at first glance this may seem like
something a little too difficult to
tackle for the devs at avalanche but i
think there are several ways they could
make it work and give players the
ability to become an animagus
for starters avalanche wouldn't need to
include a ton
of animal options here they could simply
include a handful of common animals that
may all have the same basic abilities
in fact according to the harry potter
canon wizards who chose to become an
animagist did not get to select a
specific animagus
instead they turned into the animal that
suited them best the main issues for the
devs here would obviously be figuring
out how to make the anime gi unique
enough but also not to the point where
certain challenges or levels would be
too easy
number two apparition if it's been a
while since you've read the books or
watched the movies apparating is
basically teleportation for wizards
being able to apparate in hogwarts
legacy would be a fantastic option for
late game fast travel even if it's
probably something we wouldn't want
right from the start of the game just
for the sake of exploration
of course there's also the issue of
hogwarts not even allowing apparition
without certain charms being lifted
again this is set way in the past so
maybe that rule is not in place yet
in fact if they wanted to go really
crazy they could actually make something
insane happen that would cause the rule
to be set in the first place
there you go avalanche there you go in
truth fast travel is something most open
world games end up having anyway
although most of them don't have the
lore to make it perfectly believable and
seamless within the world
in the harry potter series students
begin learning to apparate in year 6.
we aren't sure yet how old our character
will be in hogwarts legacy
or if we'll be playing through all seven
years early rumors and leaks indicated
we will play as a student in year five
but none of that has been confirmed as
of yet
now even though you can't apparate in
and out of hogwarts
students at the school did have the
option of taking a series of classes
taught by wizards from the ministry of
magic
this took place in harry potter's sixth
year and they were also required to pass
an exam before they could do it legally
now unlike number one on our list this
should actually be fairly simple to
implement as most open world games today
have a fast travel system in place
at least by the end of the game tying
fast travel into apparating though would
really be adding a level of detail we
potterheads have been known to obsess
over
number three seasonal weather changes as
each harry potter book takes place over
the course of a single year there were
always key moments fans looked forward
to with each book
such as halloween christmas quidditch
season and end-of-year exams
okay maybe we didn't look forward to the
exams weather changes are also a great
way to keep things feeling fresh
visually throughout a game you can
really show off your environments and
highlight different details as you move
between the seasons
we also saw the harry potter movies make
references to weather changes throughout
the school year
usually using the whomping willow to do
that now actually i think this one has a
very high chance of happening weather
changes are something we've seen in
games for quite some time now
but i hope they don't stop there fingers
crossed we actually get changing scenery
and decorations within
the castle as well hogwarts at halloween
hogwarts at christmas yes
please give it to me avalanche given how
common weather changes are in video
games and the fact that hogwarts legacy
is all about immersing ourselves in the
wizarding world
i fully expect this to be a feature when
the game ships
number four polyjuice potion i think i'm
gonna be sick
we first learn about paula juice potion
in harry potter and the chamber of
secrets when harry and ron pose as
slytherins to try and learn of draco
malfoy's connection to the
heir of slytherin polyjuice would end up
playing a prominent role throughout the
rest of the series as we see it used
several times in key moments i think
this would be a fun addition to the game
as a potion that could be used to
complete certain side quests
okay just imagine this for a second
you're playing as a dark wizard and
you're tasked with the objective
of becoming one of the hogwarts
professors then maybe you have to go and
meet with the headmaster to obtain
some information that you need to do
something nefarious
polyjuice would also give us a way to
explore all the other house common rooms
much like harry and ron did
in year two with the slytherin common
room number five house elves in the
kitchens
okay this one isn't so much of a feature
i admit but it would be an
awesome easter egg for longtime fans of
the series
helga hufflepuff one of the four
hogwarts founders was known for her
tolerance and generosity she's the one
who's responsible for giving house elves
the opportunity to work in the hogwarts
kitchens for their safety
with this game being open world there's
a good chance we'll be able to explore
large sections of hogwarts just imagine
being able to sneak into the hogwarts
kitchens at night to chat with the house
elves working there
perhaps avalanche could even take it a
step further by having side quests that
aid the house elves or even take place
in the kitchens themselves
we've already had a number of races and
magical creatures confirmed to be in
hogwarts legacy so i'd actually be
surprised if we don't see house elves in
the final game
they're a key part of the world and
avalanche could really go the extra mile
if they had them show up in the hogwarts
kitchens
number six quidditch we already know
brooms and flying are in the game as
we've seen students gearing up for a
flying lesson in the trailer
so it would be amazing to see the devs
take things a little bit further by
letting us play quidditch for
our house quidditch has been featured in
a few of the harry potter video games
already and even got its own game in
2003 with ea's harry potter quidditch
world cup one of the key components of
any open world game is to have
extra activities and side quests that
help to build up the world and give you
more to do in addition to the main
campaign
quidditch is a perfect candidate for
that purpose the question here is how
deep do they want to go
should quidditch be part of the
storyline where you play against other
houses
or should it be more informal and
recreational something you can do at any
time with fellow classmates
or maybe they could really go the extra
mile
let us have it both ways let you play
quidditch anytime you want this could be
considered
practicing with your own house then at
various points throughout the story you
could participate in
actual matches against the other houses
since quidditch has been done in video
games before which would give avalanche
a framework to work from
and we already know flying by broomstick
is for sure in i think this one has a
decent shot at happening
number seven the house cup we already
know the four hogwarts houses will be
featured prominently throughout the game
the trailer actually gives us a glimpse
of the sorting ceremony where we can see
older students
who have already been sorted seated at
their house tables to look on
the trailer also features plenty of
references to gryffindor ravenclaw
hufflepuff and slytherin
considering that we'll learn many kinds
of magic and take classes like potions
herbology and transfiguration
it only makes sense for us to compete
against classmates for high scores
based on how high we score we could
receive house points that accumulate
throughout the game
if there's quidditch that would also
affect the point total at the end of the
year
should your house emerge victorious it
would be amazing to see the great hall
decorated with your house colors and
sigil
this type of point system actually lends
itself very well to a video game and
since we already know the houses will
play a role
i think this has a pretty solid chance
to be in the final game
number 8 romance
as harry ages throughout the original
series we see relationships and romance
take on a more prominent role
romance really started to take center
stage and goblet of fire with the yule
ball
that's where we saw ron's jealousy over
victor crum asking hermione to the yule
ball
books five six and seven saw even more
romance with characters having first
kisses
going through breakups and even getting
married in the case of bill and fleur
when it comes to video games romantic
partner options have become more and
more popular with both developers and
fans it just so happens that many of
these games fall squarely within the
same action rpg genre as hogwarts legacy
some of the most prominent games in
recent memory with romance options would
be the witcher
mass effect and dragon age i could see
this as something that the devs don't
really want to spend their time on in a
world where they already have to worry
about
magical creatures powerful spells and
brewing potions but then again the game
does take place at a school for teens
and pre-teens a place where
relationships dramatically shape
one's experience throughout school i'll
consider this one a toss-up
number nine multiplayer co-op to be fair
to avalanche here they're telling us
up front that hogwarts legacy is a
single-player adventure
at the same time i know a lot of fans
want this to happen it's not out of the
realm of possibility that we could see a
co-op mode added somewhere down the line
after all the only thing better than
learning spells flying brooms and
brewing potions is doing it along with a
friend
they could even have specific co-op
levels that can only be completed with
the help of a friend
i do think there's a chance we could see
this added at some point down the road
but right now i would have to rate the
odds as pretty low
number 10 unique magic based on light
and dark
the devs early communication on hogwarts
legacy has heavily focused on the
concept of player choice
in fact the game is all about the legacy
our character will leave at hogwarts
with this being such a prominent focus i
think the chances are pretty good that
we'll see different gameplay elements
that change based on if we play as good
or instead choose to delve into the dark
side of magic one of my favorite series
from the ps3 era of video games is
infamous if you aren't familiar with
this open world superhero title from
sucker punch studios
it also featured a morality system that
gave you a choice between good and evil
infamous really made you feel this in
terms of the powers you wielded
evil spells should be more violent and
aggressive whereas light spells should
be more restorative and defensive
if the early leaked trailer is any
indication we can already count on
seeing basic spells such as alohomora
depulso
and lumos among others but these spells
aren't inherently good or bad
the obvious answer here for dark magic
would be the unforgivable curses
crucio avodacadavra and imperio on the
light side maybe we'd get something like
the patronus charm which is incredibly
difficult for any wizard but even more
so for wizards who don't have a happy
enough memory to draw from
the biggest problem here is that this
wouldn't really match up with the canon
in the original series there really
isn't dark magic
as even good witches and wizards are
capable of casting an unforgivable curse
maybe this is where avalanche could use
some of their creative freedom with the
world to add a couple of light spells
and a couple of dark spells that are
only possible if you go down that
respective path
would you guys like to see something
like that or would you prefer they stick
to the canon at the very least i do
think we could get different visual
effects for our spells based on if we're
light or dark
hopefully you guys can tell just how
excited i am to learn even more about
this game and i know you are too
i definitely plan on making even more
hogwarts legacy videos so make sure you
hit that subscribe button before you go
and go ahead and give this video a
thumbs up as well as always thank you
guys so much for watching
i'll talk to you again soon